what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are gonna watch tales
of the Jedi episode three decided we're
dividing these up okay so first we're
like let's put it all in one go in one
video finding more to talk about is
really enjoyable and by we I mean me and
Michael Bay from Omni Medias media Omni
media here today what's going on there
Michael how are you buddy hanging in
there man hanging in there really
excited to see where uh this next one
goes because man these have been so
different already these have been great
I really I really love I really like the
first one a lot and I love the last one
so same let's see if it's maintains that
trajectory or if it's going to be like
an episode of Saturday Night Live
keep you hooked in the first couple then
you're like it's getting rough now but
anyway guys leave a like use the force
to leave a like when it doesn't take too
much force and uh full length
watch-alongs where you sync it with your
own copy
you know we got to cut these up here
over at our patreon cover a bunch of
stuff over there exclusively as well
follow Michael B Omni media over on his
YouTube channel fantastic reaction
Channel as amazing commentary I really
love really love everything you guys
watch so many of his videos so make sure
to do that let's get to it
oh by the way the music's been amazing
in these last two episodes
yeah I mentioned that yeah
shoot
we need to make a note this time yeah
to say it again
more Dooku
guess so
[Music]
this one's called Injustice you've been
studying that tablet hey are the answers
you need over Master country's death in
that file
some time has passed he's got a beard
now we cannot involve ourselves in local
political skirmishes unless requested by
the Jedi High Council or Senate your
Devotion to rules is sometimes inspiring
and sometimes yeah
foreign
oh God
I don't know why that feels so
foreboding is this when the real divide
happens
this is an interesting pairing though
because you know mace would have on a
dime if he needed to just murked Anakin
I wonder how much time has passed
enough for that schmexy beard man
welcome to rax's secundus I am Jedi
master window and this is Master Dooku
we are here to see Senator larik we are
saddened by what happened to master
katri she was well respected and will be
missed [ __ ] I will take you to
senator larik
dude those those claws
I know
wakanda forever
[Laughter]
I was contacted by these Rebels I
confided as much to mastercatchery when
she arrived
be in the Jedi that she was she refused
to let me out of her sight and she paid
for it
with her life
this guy's full of [ __ ] yeah
this is shady as dude yeah
I'd like to see where you and Country
went to meet this Informer
to go back there and relive the incident
would be heartbreaking you okay
we responded to the Senator's distress
signal by the time we arrived
it was too late to save master cutri
let us be on our way
Senator looks like Abraham from The
Walking Dead would you want catry to
leave without finding out what happened
to you I would want her to follow
protocol
come on mace he's gotta have a little
bit of heart in this
[Music]
so she struck that tree with a
lightsaber
[Music]
something happened here
[Music]
that looks like a blaster Shot firing
upon her immediately
from what I can remember
terrifying
there's like a Noir quality to this
episode I was just thinking of like L.A
Noir like the terrible lying some of
those characters too
and getting a sense of that right now
someone fired from the direction of the
ship but a Jedi to succumb to a surprise
attack is rare
unless that attack is from someone one
would trust like you
stand down
it's killed her
oh
oh
huh
that I did not see coming yeah no whoa
what the
whoa whoa whoa
what the heck
G
[Music]
murder them oh dude
I love obstructed lightsabers man tell
us what really happened you and all of
the Senate puppets were still Reckoning
no
[Music]
so I'm I guess the the quote-unquote
rebels just infiltrated his security we
are part of a group who learned lyric
was using ascendancy to become rich at
the expense of our people and planet
okay okay he was selling off our planet
Peace by peace all from his comfortable
residence on Far Away Coruscant that
goddamn course
[Laughter]
why didn't you take this to the proper
authorities Jedi are lap dogs of the
Senate the bidding always comes first
Jedi claim peace but mostly keep Law and
Order for the rich and Powerful exactly
we were just talking about this in the
last episode yeah she would have
listened
he knows he's like yeah
oh I'm thinking I don't condone your
methods but you had every right to
protect your planet make sure your
people don't lose hearts and evolve so
much it is the only way you truly have
victory
[Music]
do you think the Jedi would truly keep
peace if they continue to take
everything the Senate says as law we are
Guided by our counsel and not by
politics nor ego
no
Mace Windu trying to drop some little
lessons in there
a little bit there's a little bit of
Truth on both sides there though
she was off the force it flowed with
certainty through it
someone's looking uncertain though I am
told you will be presented with Master
catfish Council seats
I will oh interesting is there something
you knew was happening before we left
for rexus oh oh you and I both were
together when the mission was assigned
you decided to interfere in a way that
led to a senator's death
I will speak to the Council on your
behalf how kind of you
this is cool
just these little things chipping away
in these origin tales and and these
little chunks with great music in it too
by the way yes man that good good music
completely remembered dementia I
mentioned the music it was great
by Kevin kiner
you know they what's really aiding these
shorts is that they feel cinematic too
you know like they don't just feel like
uh
uh sorry if I was recording or not
like I would have sucked they don't just
feel like because you know some like
there are episodes of Clone Wars that at
times felt like this is true like like
so much of the last season especially
felt I feel like so cinematic yeah for
sure and they would usually pick and
choose their episodes that would feel
that way and I think like each one of
these really do
but to sound ultimately pretentious they
you know they they the the film part of
short film feels very present you know
what I mean so for sure yeah this is
this is great and then even like the
distrust because you could feel there's
like a camaraderie and a kinship with
them even though there's a difference
and and and uh ideologies and and uh
questioning of Mythology between between
them methodology between them
but that that little Stinger at the end
there with him getting the Council seat
is like creates that bigger divide again
of can you really trust anyone here like
there is a divide a distrust and
especially when it was the seat of the
person they were investigating exactly
it almost seemed like
there's an agenda like yeah when they
before they even left I don't know
whether there was or wasn't it's it's
already
too late that with all these other
kind of like
seeds that have been planted with Dooku
from the other things you've seen
exactly from every
what because
compared to the
you know episode one to episode two from
Ahsoka to that first Dooku story
this one
you know there there was a big divide as
far as like the tones and what we were
tackling there but this one really
accentuates the one that came before
and we almost pretty much are just
picking up
with those same breadcrumbs and seeing
like more pile on top of it yeah
um a thousand percent with the
investigation with another world
um that is being abused by their Senator
by Coruscant by and the Jedi being just
so far removed
from the actual people that are being
governed that they're supposed to
protect and that there's whether they
see it or not and I think like that's
one of the things too is like when he
questioned mace about you know
before they left about whether or not
you know are we are we doing the right
thing here or if this person would have
come to the Jedi would they have been
heard
I don't know man because it seems like
they just like we've seen like later
down the line like they they are so
unaware of how far removed they are from
the the people that they just don't they
just don't see it
and that's one of the things is like
Dooku's constantly out here in these
these places seen all the different ways
that the Jedi are kind of
not doing what they're supposed to be
doing or at least not doing it as
effectively as they should
I don't know it's really interesting
yeah this is it's good stuff I mean
especially with
um the way they're handling Dooku it's
kind of like on that I think the
terminology's uh
self-fulfilling prophecy where he's like
he's just he's already got the beliefs
and any little it like you you have Mace
Windu who can hear out
what that guy was saying that guard
which by the way good good Twist on it
because it was like yeah seems so
obvious like oh it's obvious that the
senator and then like oh what is a
complete opposite actually it was a nice
flipper a nice Switcheroo there
but the self-fulfilling prophecy side is
you know like he
he'll interpret and and the way he um
digests information is going to be
different than
then like Mace Windu will hear the exact
same thing
and you know obviously Mace Windu does
not go down the dark path
where mace or uh Dooku will hear that
and go
see
um no proven right it's just the more we
get the more ride I am and when all
management
protocol you know
he's like but Dooku is looking at him
with suspicion he's like I was
I was there yeah with you like maybe the
council had this agenda beforehand but
like he's already he's so disillusioned
at this point like you said any new
piece of evidence he's just like aha
yeah I told you and now he's to the
point where he's even distrusting
somebody who is like he even said it
like when they went out there it was
like your adherence to the rules is
admirable and maddening yes so like he
already knows that
and by his own volition admits that mace
is
for better for worse committed to the
Creed yeah itself so and mace is one of
the even if he does fall under the bale
of the dark side or whatever like where
you know he can't see the forest through
the trees because of what's been going
on
his values are aren't corrupted yeah and
to the point where even at the end of
the episode he's still looking at mace
and being like
suspicious of him shows how much this is
affecting him and his judgment
ah it's good stuff with good music
great music great music throughout
all right guys well that's it for
episode uh three yeah three time to move
on to episode four been really enjoying
this so far
[Music]